- This is really, really special.
This recipe, I've been drinking it
since I was like five years old.
Yes, it has a rum in it.
(beep)
Hello, everyone.
My name is Toni.
I love making delicious
comfort food inspired
by my Afro-Latina background.
Today, Tasty challenged me to make a dish
using ingredients starting
with the same letter.
So let's see what letter I pick.
Oh.
Letter C.
All right, let's do it.
I got the letter C.
Choclos, carnitas.
- [Producer] Just so you know,
you only have 15 minutes.
- 15 minutes?
- [Producer] 15 minutes to shop.
- All right. So I'm gonna go
ahead and pivot to dessert
because dessert is easy and it's fast,
and it's limited ingredients.
And I am gonna choose an empanada
It's what I know, it's what I love.
I can fill it with anything. Let's go.
Okay, so the base of an empanada
is gonna be the filling.
So I need something sweet.
I need a fruit to put inside.
Cranberries, coconut, cantaloupe.
Oh, cosmic crisp apples.
Perfect. This is amazing.
These are gonna be super sweet
and they're gonna add a nice bite
and crunch to the empanadas.
So I have the base for my filling.
We're gonna use apples.
It's fall, so of course
I'm gonna use cinnamon.
This is too easy.
You should have gave
me a harder challenge.
All right, So I need something
to kind of bind the empanada together.
Sweet condensed milk.
I don't know what I'm making,
but we're gonna take it.
Key ingredient to any dessert
is gonna be ice cream.
So I'm thinking we got
chocolate chip, we got caramel.
Coffee that's gonna be perfect
for my empanada dessert.
I just know it.
So the whole reason I chose empanadas
'cause I knew I could
use cornmeal as the base.
So we're gonna grab that cause
that's gonna be my dough.
Corn meal. There's no corn meal?
Okay, I see what you guys did here.
Can I use corn flakes?
Cake flour?
I still want something.
Corn syrup, perfect.
Perfect.
Coconut cream.
(timer buzzes)
- [Producer] Hey, you're 15 minutes is up.
- I think I got everything I needed.
So I'll meet you back at the kitchen.
All right, everyone.
So I am back at the kitchen
and I am ready to get started.
I got all of my ingredients
with the letter C
and I narrowed it down to some
that I really think I can
make something special with.
So I got some coconut milk, my cake flour
which is gonna be the base of my empanada.
I had to get my coffee
ice cream, of course.
Tasty was nice enough to
give me some pantry staples.
We have some water, some
butter, and some sugar.
Let's get started.
It's time to make the empanada dough.
So we're gonna pour our cake
flour into our food processor.
Next I'm gonna add my salt, of course.
And then I'm going to add
my butter, my pantry staple.
And we're gonna pulse this
until the butter is evenly distributed.
(chuckles)
I always struggle with this part.
There we go. Now we're gonna pulse.
(processor pulsing)
So we're going for that
coarse sand consistency.
So next you're gonna add some water
to your flour butter mixture,
and you're gonna pulse
while you're doing this
so you wanna add your water in gradually
So my dough is coming together
I'm gonna check the consistency
just to make sure it's right
and then we're gonna dump it
on the table and knead it.
This makes me happy.
Perfect empanada dough from scratch.
So now it's time to knead our dough.
So we're gonna dump it all out.
I am happy that I chose empanadas
because I grew up eating them.
So we're gonna get our
empanada dough together.
I'm actually surprised at how
well this cake flour's going
because I've actually
never used it before,
but I wanted to do a
traditional Columbian empanada
using the corn meal,
but it wasn't available.
So I'm pivoting to what I know best.
This is gonna be a more Puerto Rican
or Dominican style empanada.
We use flour and the cake flour
is actually doing really well.
So now we're gonna take our empanada dough
and we're gonna wrap it in Saran wrap,
and then we're just gonna
let it sit for 20 minutes.
So after my dough has rested
it is time to cut the dough into eights.
So I'm gonna go ahead and take my dough,
cut it down the middle
working on my muscles.
You want them to be
like little pizza pies.
So we're cutting them into eighths, guys.
So next I'm gonna take one
of my little pizza pie eights
and you're gonna roll
it into a little circle.
We wanna make sure our empanada
dough stays nice and moist.
So we're gonna move it and we're
gonna put it under a towel.
You wanna make sure you're
getting these nice round balls
that are even, keep the
consistency together
'cause we want it to taste good,
but we want it to look good too.
I like to roll mine by hand,
but you can also use a table.
You can use whatever you like
as long as you have
these nice little balls.
So I rolled all of my balls
and now it's time to make our disc.
I'm going to take a little plastic bag
I'm using a tortilla press,
but honestly you can use
whatever you have at home.
You can use a rolling pin,
you can use a bottle of
tequila, whatever you have.
You just wanna make
these into nice circles.
So you wanna make sure you're
gonna press nice and firm
or however you're rolling them out
'cause you want them to be nice and flat.
And you want a sphere
that looks like this.
Perfect. Put that to the side
and then I'm gonna get another one going.
And while you're here you can
listen to your favorite music.
This is like the most
relaxing part of the process,
and my opinion is a nice little workout.
Okay guys, so I decided on
the base for my empanada.
I don't wanna just throw
the apples in there.
So I'm gonna make a caramel from scratch.
I'm super excited about it.
So I'm gonna put all of my
ingredients into my pot.
I decided to use corn
syrup because of the C,
and the corn syrup is gonna
help me stabilize my caramel.
So we're gonna dump my sugar in there
and then I'm going to add my water,
a nice pantry ingredient.
Thank you, Tasty.
So when you're making caramel at home
it's important that you put
all of your ingredients in
and you're gonna cover it.
You're not gonna toss it
up, you're not gonna stir it
'cause you don't want
your sugar to crystallize.
You're gonna let it cook
and you're gonna take it slow and low.
So now that we have this
beautiful amber color,
I'm gonna go ahead and add my butter in,
and then I'm going to whisk my butter in.
And now I'm gonna go
ahead and add in my cream
and you wanna whisk really fast.
Whew. It smells delicious.
So next you're gonna go ahead
and remove it from the heat.
And I'm going to continue
to whisk because it is hot
until the caramel is
a nice smooth texture.
Okay, so now it's time to
make our apple filling.
I'm melting my butter
and I'm gonna take my cosmic crisp apples
that I sliced and diced
and just tossed them in.
I'm gonna coat them in that butter,
and you're gonna give them a nice toss.
These apples are actually really tasty.
They're gonna give the
empanada a nice crisp.
Now I'm just gonna add
in a touch of water.
The water's gonna help soften the apples,
so you're gonna get that crunch
in that bite in the empanada,
but it's still gonna be nice and smooth.
So we're gonna let our
cosmic crisp apples cook
for about 8 to 10 minutes
on medium low heat.
So I'll be back when they're
ready for the next step.
Now my apples are nice and caramelized.
They have a nice golden brown color.
They're soft but not too soft.
So we're gonna take them and
transfer them to a small bowl,
so that they can cool down
and be a nice filling for my empanada.
So my cosmic crisp apples are cooling.
It's time for the next step.
We went ahead and we chilled
the apples and the caramel
because if they're too warm
they'll break the empanada doughs.
Now that those are chilled,
we're gonna take our
empanada rounds and our disc,
and we're gonna take a scoop of each
and we're gonna scoop
it right in the center.
Next you're gonna get a
nice scoop of your apples
and then you're gonna
fold over your empanada.
And there's gonna be a little bit of space
between the filling and the edges,
and you're gonna press down.
Now that our empanadas nice and filled
I'm gonna go ahead and decorate the edges.
So I'm gonna take my thumb
and I am going to make these
little flowers, I call them.
And after they're fried this
will look really beautiful.
But if you can't do this
you can use a fork at
home and press down too.
And at the end you have something
that looks beautiful just like this.
So it's time to fry our empanada dough.
So I'm gonna go ahead and take them
and drop them in hot oil one by one.
I've never had a sweet empanada
that I've made at home,
so I'm really excited to
see how these come out.
So I'm gonna fry the empanada dough
until they're nice and crispy.
You want a nice golden brown color.
So I'm gonna watch them closely
'cause they only take about
two to three minutes to cook.
And then after that I
have a special surprise C.
So now our empanadas are ready.
They are perfectly crispy
and nice and golden brown.
So I'm gonna take them out
and I'm gonna let them rest on the side.
Oh my goodness, I don't
know if I can wait.
These look so delicious.
These empanadas are gorgeous.
They have this beautiful
golden brown color.
They're gonna be so sweet and savory.
Ugh. I took one of my C
ingredients, cinnamon,
and I mixed it with some of the sugar
that I had in the pantry
and I made cinnamon sugar.
So while your empanadas are hot,
you're gonna dust them with
that delicious cinnamon sugar.
My empanadas need something
to really tie it together.
So I decided that I'm
gonna make a coquito glaze.
A coquito is a traditional
Puerto Rican holiday drink.
It's similar to a eggnog minus the eggs,
and I have all of my ingredients
to bring it all together.
So I'm gonna start with my C ingredient,
my confectioners' sugar,
and then I'm gonna add
in my coconut cream.
And these are actually all ingredients
of the traditional holiday drink.
So this is why I'm so happy.
And then we're gonna put
in our condensed milk.
Next, we're just gonna add
in a little bit of cinnamon,
and we're just gonna whisk that together
until it forms a nice glaze.
If it's too thick like it is here,
I'm gonna add in a touch of
water to kind of loosen it up.
This is really, really special.
This recipe using an empanada,
but also being able to use
coquito which is a holiday drink.
I've been drinking it since
I was like five years old.
Yes, it has rum in it.
So I'm done whisking my coquito glaze.
You want it to be a nice thick texture.
It's going to be a nice finishing touch.
Look at that.
Perfect. This really
reminds me of my childhood.
It's perfect. You get like
all the flavors minus the rum.
Maybe I'll add some in later.
So I'm really excited to eat one of these.
They smell amazing.
It's gonna be mouthwatering.
So I'm gonna top them off
with my coquito glaze.
These are so gorgeous and I
like to go back a second time.
The more coquito glaze, the better.
My empanadas are all glazed up.
It's time to plate.
These look absolutely delicious.
I can't wait to see if they actually taste
as good as they look,
but I'm sure they do because
I made them, of course.
I'm ready to try it.
But first, my final C ingredient
is gonna be this delicious
coffee ice cream.
And I am going to place it
right on the side of my coquito.
And for my favorite part of the whole day,
I get to try my delicious dessert.
Let's see how these coquito
glazed cinnamon empanadas are,
and let's go for it.
(upbeat festive music)
And now I'm gonna take a
bite of my coffee ice cream
to just bring it all together.
That's actually delicious.
I taste the cinnamon,
taste the crisp apples.
The cosmic crisp apples, CC.
I have some of that coquito glaze.
I have the coffee ice cream.
Thank you so much for joining me
on this super fun adventure.
Using letter C was a challenge,
but I think I pulled it off.
You guys tell me what
you think in the comment.
What challenge do you
like to see me do next?
Let me know. Thanks for stopping by.
(upbeat festive music)